all right shane
yes sir shane uh where'd you grow up
where are you from where is i mingle
county west virginia
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were a
kid
yes i had both my parents my mother was
a hard worker my father was an alcoholic
but my father died when i was 15 you
know
from drugs and alcohol i'm sorry that's
okay
and that just put a big hole in my world
i like i used
everything negative it made my whole
life negative everything i just fed into
that
i become a drug addict like that is that
when drug use started for you yes sir
you guys were very poor oh very poor my
mom was a cna which they make like 10 11
an hour and that's what we lived off of
how many kids
five wow four boys and a girl
how far did you go in school to the 11th
grade well midway through the eleventh
yeah yeah so after that where did you
where'd your life go after that nowhere
i
became a drug addict then by the time
i'm 20 i'm locked up
i'm 33 right now and just got off just
got released today
how many years were you in prison seven
straight
seven straight years seven straight
years wow and what
did those seven years change you in any
way yeah they did they made me grow up a
lot you know made me
stop taking everything for granted and
and realized that you know
life does go on while i was in prison
though
i had to have a ged class to make a job
right
i would go to ged class and sleep every
day and the teacher he came back and he
woke me up one day and oh man
he said he called me boyd he said boy
won't you uh
just do me a favor and make your ged man
he said you're a smart kid
he said i'm getting ready to retire in
six months he said if you don't make
your ged you're gonna be stuck here and
this is a hell hole it's huttonsville
west virginia penitentiary it's like
top notch guantanamo bay [ __ ]
i said i took him seriously i went back
the next day i said danny you know what
i'm going to try to make my ged
so i made my ged in 63 days and i made
it with a 3174 score
which is a scholarship anywhere in
america
i've not pursued it though but i didn't
make my ged and i did become a man
when i got out i went to texas i found a
nurse
she's never been high like we've been
together for two years now we have a
four-month-old son
doing good it's just how are you
together with you were in prison that
you were with her
no i met her from in prison oh my sister
lives in texas you're dating her while
you're in prison
i talked to her we didn't date we just
called it then when i went out there and
shook her hand when i met her i just it
was a whole new vibe
she's a blessing her name is rosio book
negra
see i'm gonna try to have another baby
with her soon as soon as i go home
so what are you gonna do with your life
now you've been out for one day
yes well i'm gonna go to texas and i'm
gonna
go to work for this construction company
where i really do the peers on the
freeways the concrete drains
and i'm going to start my own pressure
washing business once i get there where
i go around these car lots
that have all these cars i say sir i'll
wash your cars
once a week for two dollars a car wash
them and dry them
that's my goal so hopefully i get it you
know
but you're telling me about the data
pastor yes that's gonna be on my free
time
i'm gonna become a pastor i gotta i got
arrested on the church steps
i fell asleep on the porch praying for
my wife and my son i got so tired i
can't move
i fall asleep and i wake up and the
police is standing over me with a
flashlight this is what you got arrested
for
no they thought i was dead this is how
they brought me back here oh i see
on my parole but yeah i'm going to
become a pastor
like here's what i said i said you know
i want to become a pastor and see what
it takes to become football basketball
coach because once i got in prison i
realized i was really good at sports
like i would go months and be the only
white person on any team
and they have real leagues in there like
they keep stats i want two championships
it's not a lot but it's amazing because
they give you fresh favorites
which is like burgers from the street so
i learned i was good and i want to
become a coach out there and there's
plenty of opportunities but
i want to become a pastor at this church
legacy where i got arrested at
i went there me and my wife had been
bickering because
me smoking marijuana she didn't agree
with it
so we hadn't seen my son all day so i
went to
church that evening i started praying i
said god please
give me my son what do i do to get my
son i want my family you know i just
want to be a family that's all i ever
wanted
i got so tired i couldn't move i fall
asleep i wake up the cops stand over me
he arrests me and brings me back here
so i wanted that church to give him that
testimony and and see what it takes to
become a pastor there
that's good for you god's like he's gave
me a whole new life out there you know
they're they're they're trying to build
us a new house now habitat for humanity
so i got a whole new blessing a whole
new life ahead of me
the kid i was i don't have to be anymore
you know i become a man i don't have to
worry about
my dad anymore because i get to be a dad
that's great
something i never could have did here
there's nothing here but
drugs and dope hoes if you know anything
about them
yeah no everyone i've talked to is i
went out there and found a real woman
she's a hospice nurse it's a blessing
you know
my mom lives out there now like we got a
whole new life ahead of us you know
i just can't wait to get there to take
advantage of it you know
you got money to get there no i'm
waiting on them the money grant me money
how much you need to get there the bus
stick is 118 dollars
yeah i caught them from the store over
here just a while ago they
they're probably nothing wild right now
trying to get me there you know yeah
i'll help you out
what what uh show me what you showed me
earlier those two pieces of styrofoam
that you you wrote in prison yeah this
is from dinner trays where they feed you
trays in the jail
and this is bible verses what can i read
them
please it says this is jeremiah 29 11
says for i know
the plans i have for you declares the
lord plans for welfare not for evil to
give you a future into hope
in jeremiah 33 verse 3 says call on to
me and i will answer you and tell you
great and hidden things that you have
not known
then psalms 41 says verse 1
blessed is the one who considers the
poor in the day of trouble
the lord delivers him and then john 10 2
says but he who enters by the door
is the shepherd of the sheep then romans
5
1 says therefore since we have been
justified by faith we have peace with
god through our lord jesus christ but
here's the best one ever
it's romans 10 10 it says brothers my
heart's desire and prayer to god is that
we all may be saved
you know and then this is
my goal as i was writing down for out
there it says
looking to start my own business take
half the month that it makes
half the money it grosses in a month and
start a trust fund for my son
get my job back at ws construction marry
my wife as soon as possible
be the best dad possible and have
another baby
enjoy life don't have to look over my
shoulder anymore
get me a race car and get to having fun
we moved in my own house by thanksgiving
so we can have thanksgiving dinner at my
house
take my wife on a cruise shortly somehow
and wake up christmas with rosie and
chase as my wife my son
just would be the best christmas ever
you know
and then phase two says
make every plan work out don't get
frustrated and give god time to fulfill
it all
find time to become a coach for football
and basketball
become a pastor preferably at legacy and
enjoy the rest of my life being humble
kind
grateful and blessed and knowing that
every sinner
has a future and every saint has a past
you know
it's beautiful thank you for sharing
that
you're welcome so what got you into
prison in the first place
armed robbery i was on oxycontin's and
i woke up july july the 13th and i
didn't have any
money and i went and robbed the store
for 500
and they gave me 30 years for robbing
that store 30 years
yes they used my brother to testify on
me he worked for that store
your brother testified again yes and
then while i'm in prison
he robbed the same store for ten
thousand dollars
and only gave him one to three years
which is 18 months
it just broke me down you know i watched
him come and leave while i'm there
for the same thing they told on me for
but i forgive him you know that's my
brother
he taught me how to tie my shoes you
know i can never hold it against him
because it's drugs you know it's the
devil
do you think the the pain that you felt
from that
watching your brother come and go for
something worse and you getting punished
unfairly perhaps do you think that
the pain you felt is what's what's
gotten you to where where you are today
yes
gave me the drive to never give up you
know it makes me like understand that i
was
i'm tough you know it showed me because
i was dependent on all of them i never
really had a job or anything you know
all i did was get high
and it just showed me that i i can't
count on myself you know it
made me just drive harder every day
whatever i was doing i don't want to win
at it because i
feel like i lose at everything you know
yeah i've heard so many stories
in appalachia who about
from people who have gone through
extreme adversity everything about
living
in appalachia is difficult carrying your
groceries into the house is difficult
because
every step is up a steep hill or you're
just different stone you know yeah it's
just it's a very difficult life
for many different reasons and it seems
like the people are
is they're just
so kind and compassionate
yeah and strong and they are they're
very strong
and they're very honest they don't have
i've given money to so many people here
that i've interviewed
and they just jump back they won't
accept it yeah
and it's like you know i i gave a man a
100 bucks yesterday
for for talking with me and he just
jumped back like what are you doing
i mean you wouldn't accept it and he
never did and that's happened so many
times here
you'll find you'll find many more like
that yeah that's the way we raise this
yeah
i'm so used to people saying that
they'll take my money and the moral is
instilled in us you know i see that a
lot out in texas
yeah we think texas has some of this too
yeah they
they people is just different it's a
different caliber here
yeah well it's it's it's so beautiful to
hear your story
yeah thank you man it's been a long
story but it's i don't have to look over
my shoulder anymore hear me i'm i'm free
now
hold you i'm 33 years old you're so
young i got my whole life ahead of me i
want to become a coast guard
you know it's what i want to do
eventually
somehow i'm going to be i want to become
a coast guard
i wouldn't even become a police officer
if they let me but they won't let me
because i don't want my son walking on
the rocks that i stumbled on near me i
don't want that
i want a better life for him and i will
do whatever it takes to see that he has
a better life
were you religious before you went to uh
prison some would not really know i
found god in prison
he felt me should i say you know
and he's real
very shane well thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you man i wish
you the best of luck though
all right thank you thank you i didn't
mean the crown you know that's all right
it's okay
i don't have to do this no more man
you had bibles in in in prison yeah they
gave this to me in prison
property of him shane dawn wallace
[Applause]
oh my favorite verses is right here